did you think you were going to get it
after that third audition you're like uh
well I kind of after Mad TV because I
only did really like just over half of a
season there I was asked back but like
at a reduced thing and my reps were like
don't do it and I was like oh okay and I
was like why did I do that and they
weren't paying you well there no way
they were paying me three thousand
dollars more a week than when I got SNL
10 years later so I made more on Mad TV
per week than than when I started
getting paid at SNL you know that's
crazy yeah were you intimidated yeah
every day did you feel intimidated SNL
for me it wasn't fun was it going in
there every day
sometimes sometimes it was the most fun
it really was and mad tv helped me
because going into SNL like I would say
the first two years I knew to just like
appreciate every day sit in the pocket
do good work put your best foot forward
and you know but understand this is you
know there are seniors and you're a
freshman and understand that
um
SNL was really kind of the first time
where I've it made me a level of
insecure I had not experienced before
like I'd certainly had always had
healthy insecurity
but SNL for me and have having done some
work since I was off of it I've sort of
realized I cared so much what everybody
thought of me because
I love that job and I love that place
and and everybody was so funny and so
smart and by the end of it it put me in
not it I was not my best self in that I
was just really
um it turned me into a pessimist and I
would not have
describe myself that way before that job
and it broke you down a little bit Yeah
Yeah by the end of it by the end of it
it was it was also like having two kids
you know it's not it's not it's a Young
Person's show it's a show that I think
wants all of you and and kind of
deserves all of you that's the best way
to do it is that like you're there as
much as you can be and you're available
for everything and then when on the off
weeks you're hanging out with everybody
and you're planning trips to Europe
Costa Rica whatever you know you're
bonding and I was I just by Nature by
having a child by being you know having
a fiance at that point I was like a
clock in clock out kind of guy and by
the time my family moved out there
you know for the first four seasons I
was flying back and forth and so I'd be
out there and do the job I could let it
consume me and then I'd come back and
there was some adjustment stuff that was
tough but then once my family was out
there it's like I gotta get to the
Winter concert I gotta I put so much
time in this my time is now more
precious to me
um which is you know which is true but
also like
not true for the rest of the show you
know what I mean so yeah it's a tricky
thing but the friends I made there the
experiences I had there like I will
never have a job as special or or that I
have more Pride about because it was the
dream job like that is speaking about
failure oh my God that's that is and I
think probably will forever be the
biggest success of my life is setting
out and going like I have a shot at this
if I train and I put myself to be in the
right place at the right time as often
as possible I have a good shot at it and
and they've got it and it worked did
were you in a sense relieved when they
didn't renew your contract yes you were
like good yes did they know you didn't
want to come back yes they knew so it
was a mutual thing there was it was
still like messy and you know lacking of
clarity or respect and all that but it
was not I was not taken by surprise by
any means did Lauren call you and say no
I just want to say that you were great
no nothing like that nope it's not in
his nature
sometimes but I think by that point our
relationship was a little
um
we just did not have that closeness at
that point